okay so we we will do Greek Theater
today now as a society every society has
a problem the problem is how do we
organize the
thinking of the people within our
society okay how do you create an
identity and in modern society there are
three
institutions that create a collective
identity for society okay so the first
would be
what exactly thank you schools right so
Public Schools you're here to learn
about the history of China you're here
to learn about the politics of China
right the idea is to make everyone think
alike or have the same basic knowledge
and worldview okay what's another
institution that does that does this in
society
the media right okay so mass media so
when you when you turn on a TV when you
read a chence newspaper it's presenting
a particular
worldview and when you absorb this
worldview you become more Chinese right
and what's the last
institution that helped us form a
collective identity in China
entertainment right mass
culture this includes um you know TV
shows this includes movies okay this
includes books does that make sense so
through these three institutions
societies can create a national
identity and um depending on your
Society you create a different worldview
right so in America Americans would want
to create an
individualistic identity
where's in China we want to create a um
collectivist identity okay so what I
will show you today is Greek society
Athenian Society was doing the same
thing okay but it was doing it it
through
theater and the main function of theater
was to create an identity as an as a
democratic citizen okay Democratic
citizen
why do we have a democracy what does it
mean to live in democracy what is your
responsibility as a citizen to be in a
democracy okay so that's what theater um
uh does in
Athens so um let me give you some
background about theater theater was
the uh formed the basic structure of
Athenian
Society so uh there are two months of
the year when everyone went to the
theater okay so uh once in Winter and
once in the summer time and they were
called the
Festival of dionis okay dionis was the
god the Greek god of um the theater of
art of music of sex of
wine and so the Festival of dianis there
were religious elements to it um but it
was mainly about watching theater and
through the process of watching theater
Athenians um created a national identity
that they all believed in okay so this
happened twice a year for one month and
it was free for everyone so it's the
rich who um paid for all the place to be
performed and that's how the rich the
aristocratic families won favor from uh
the people in fact Athenians considered
going to the theater the greatest
Birthright of being an Athenian okay
that was the privilege and the right of
being an Athenian it was the um highest
honor in Athens to participate in the
festival as a
playright and every Festival there' be
two there would be two competitors okay
and they were called the
protagonist okay and the antagonist
so today um we know that protagonist
means the hero of a novel antagonist
means the villain of a novel but back
then all this meant was you were the
first competitor and then the antagonist
was the second competitor
okay and the entire point of theater was
to promote democracy in Athens and they
did that through many mechanisms um
first of all whoever won the festival
was decided by popular vote okay the
entire process of theater was Democratic
so there were no professional actors in
Athens people were selected from the
community uh to act out the the play and
everyone participated in
watching um the play in fact the largest
EMP theater these are all outdoor
theaters in a could hold 10,000 people
okay 10 15,000 people the maximum
population of Athens was 50,000 people
okay so this a a huge Community event
that brought everyone together and they
loved the
theater
um the three most famous playwrights in
Athens at that time were
Isis um
sopes and Europe uh europees okay and
the these were really playwrights poets
but they were first and foremost
prophets of democracy they were teachers
of democracy who told the Athenian
people why do we have democracy why is
democracy good and what and how should
we protect and promote our
democracy all right so in their place
the very heart and soul of their plays
was about the promotion of democracy in
Athens and these three were the most
admired of all the playwrights everyone
at that time wanted to be a playwright
because that was the highest honor um in
Athens okay so to win first place at the
festival Dianes is like winning the
Nobel Prize in physics today okay so um
what I will do now is go over the most
famous plays so we can understand how
they promoted democracy uh through their
artwork but are there any questions so
far before I
continue yes it's an
Ampitheater okay so that's a great
question about Acoustics we call this
Acoustics so how the theater was
designed was like this okay you had the
stage and then um the theater was
designed design like this like an oval
okay so in other words um the sound was
captured in like a cavern in a cave so
there was resonance but obviously you
were required to shout out the words
slowly soone can hear okay that's the
first thing second thing is these plays
were so popular everyone memorized the
lines you understand so they already
knew the content of the plays and they
but they wanted to participate in the
community aspect of the play does that
make does that make sense so the two
things is uh the theater was designed in
a way so that sound traveled very U
freely in the theater so everyone can
hear but also everyone memorize the
lines anyway okay does that make sense
okay great question all right any more
questions before I
continue all right so let's talk about
issus okay because he was really the
first of the major play rights and he
wrote a play called
oresa and I will explain to you the plot
of the Ora before I explain to you the
meaning in an interpretation of the play
okay so um all these plays comes from
Greek mythology because everyone knows
mythology um and so what the play rades
did was they took material from Greek
mythology and and package it in a
contemporary context to explore modern
themes okay all right so therea um the
play set in a place called Aros and
during the masine period okay so this is
before the Bronze Age collaps Ming in
Greece um Argos was the most powerful
City in Ming and Greece and um when the
king died he left the throne to his
eldest son named at trees okay
but often what happens in these cases is
the younger brother refuses to accept
the authority of the eldest and he
Rebels okay so a war was thought over
the Argos Throne a treaties won and then
his brother comes and begs for
forgiveness and a treaties being the
king says you're my brother I want to
show I'm I'm a benevolent King so I will
forgive you and to show that I forgive
you we will I will host for you a
banquet and a feast
okay and so the younger brother is very
happy about this but during the feast
before the feast what a treat a treaties
does is he kills all the sons of his
younger brother and he cooks them and
during the feast he feeds it to his
younger brother and when his younger
brother finds out about this okay he he
dies after this but before he dies he
curses a treaties and says curse upon
you and your house because a feast is a
contract between you and the gods okay
when you hold a feast you promise of
gods this Feast will be peaceful and so
people trust you and come and eat your
food so when you poison your food like
this you are in some of the Gods so I
curse you and your entire house okay and
then he dies but before he dies um um
his son agus okay agus escapes okay so
his only remaining son is agus and agus
is responsible now for adventuring the
death of his family okay all right so a
treaties becomes king he has two sons
who inherit his throne okay the first is
Egan who becomes king of Argos and he is
the king of kings he is the one who
start the children war and launch an
invasion of Troy okay and his brother is
menw who becomes king of
Sparta and they both marry sisters okay
they marry s two sisters AG man on
marri's
clestra and menas marries Helen okay
this is important because remember helin
runs away to Troy and Menos tells his
brother EG Menan gets upset and they
agree to organize this massive Greek
army to invade destroy Troy and get
Helen Back
okay but when they're about to set sail
for Troy there's no
win and egam Manon knows the gods are
not happy with them okay so EG Manan
consults a fortune teller who tells him
how to win the favor of the Gods he
tells EG Manon you have to sacrifice
your daughter
ifia and at this point Egan man should
be like um I'm not going to do that I'm
not going to sacrifice my daughter
Eugenia so that I could go to Troy and
why do I want to go to Troy in the first
place right hell is not my wife it's
men's wife not my problem right I should
just give this up because obviously the
gods don't want me to go that's what he
should do but instead he's like fine
I'll I my daughter okay so he kills his
daughter in Virginia the wind uh is
released from the skies and they set
sail to Troy okay and we know what
happens they're there for 10 years and
end up destroying
Troy who's really pissed now who's
really angry
now who's who's really angry about all
this clan mestra right the wife of a
Manar because their daughter has been
killed for like no reason
okay so clra while Egon is away for 10
years she plots her revenge what she
does is she finds Aus and they become
lovers okay and they plot how to avenge
the death of Eugenia so 10 years later
when Egon comes back from Troy
Victorious kestra kills him
okay and she makes agius now king of
Argos the problem is that egam Manon has
a son named
aristes and aristes uh during this time
was exiled from Argos okay and now
aristes upon hearing the death of um his
father he is now
HonorBound to kill his mother
now obviously he doesn't want to do that
okay so he's struggling
emotionally about what to do so he
consults um Apollo who is basically the
God of Justice and Apollo tells him you
are right and just to want to advance
your father okay so R's goes back to
Argos and he kills his mother
clestra and Augustus and now he's king
of Argos the problem now is because he's
killed his mother there are these demons
called the
furies who come up from the underworld
and they begin to haunt him okay they're
torturing him and
aristes um becomes so tortured he runs
away from Argos and he's trying to run
away from Furies but the furies refuse
to let him go and Ori says to them I
killed my mother in order to avenge my
father that was the right and just thing
to do and the the say to
him um we are old
gods we are responsible for maintaining
order and structure in the universe one
thing that you cannot do is kill your
parents especially your mother by doing
so you are breaking the order of the
universe therefore we will haunt you for
the rest of
Eternity we will not let you go
okay aristes goes talks to Apollo and
Apollo tries to intercede on the on
behalf of aristes and the F say to him
you are a young God you are a new God we
are the old gods we are much older than
you are we are much wiser than you are
you have no authority over us we don't
care about Justice we don't care about
the laws of men we care about the laws
of the universe and arises has broken
the law of the universe okay so now
orisses is in a lot of trouble and so in
an act of desperation the last thing he
does is he runs to Athens where Athena
is and Athena is the goddess of wisdom
so aristes tells Athena the godess his
story and he begs for her help okay and
Athena takes pity on aristes and she
says
basically I'm going to convene a jury
okay of 500 Athenian
citizens and you will tell you will make
your case before them the furies will
make their case before them and they
will decide whether or not you are
guilty okay so both aristes and the
fairies make their case and morally
speaking both cases are compelling okay
right because even though clestra killed
man on the fact of the matter is eg
Manon was an right EG Manan
killed their daughter for no particular
reason and then he went off to Troy and
killed a lot of people for like no
reason as well okay so both
cases uh were very strong and so at the
end of the day
250 Athenians decided aesus was guilty
250 decided he was uh innocent okay so
so it's what we call hung jury okay it
was divided evenly so what then happens
now is Athena comes in and says that
because you are deadlocked I will be the
deciding vote I vote in favor of aristes
okay so now aristes is free to go home
and live his life in peace now the FY
say to her no no no no no no we don't
accept your laws Athena okay and then
Athena says to them fine you guys I'll
make you a deal okay right now you're
demons and every fears and hates
you
but I will now make
you stand for justice truth and
righteousness so that we thethan people
will worship you and admire you okay and
the fies say okay that's a pretty good
deal okay so the fies accept this deal
and arus is allowed to go home and the
story ends okay does that make sense
so that's a
story why so what's the relevance of the
story well for Athens it tells them
where democracy comes from okay right
Athenians Athena the goddess herself
gave democracy to
Athens right but it also tells them how
what a tremendous gift this is because
by giving the Athenian people democracy
it basically gave them the power of gods
right because when you have these 500
jurors how each of them has the same
power and authority of the god Athena
herself Athena can only cast one vote
right okay and so what this is telling
the Athenian people is the gods gave you
democracy honor them
by taking it very seriously okay when
you
vote do so very seriously L because when
you vote in a good way meaning you've
fought very clear clearly um over your
decision then you bring Justice truth
you bring Justice and truth and
righteousness into the
world okay does that make
sense and that's why I say iselis is a
profit of democracy because through this
play He Is Telling the Athenian people
where democracy come from why it's
important and what they can do to ensure
democ stays in Athens okay any questions
so far about
this all
right okay let's move on to sop sopes
okay so sop wrote many plays his most
famous is the edus trilogy okay edus
Trilogy now um you may have heard of the
edus trilogy but I will summarize the
story for you okay so what happened is
in the city of
Thieves a king and his wife they have a
young son and as is a custom at that
time they go see a fortune teller and
the fortune teller tells them your son
is going to kill you the father and
marry the mother and the King freaks out
and he's like I don't want that so he
tells he orders his Soldier to go out
and kill the baby okay and the soldier
takes the baby and again it's it's just
a baby like like you know maybe a few
days a few weeks old he goes out in the
woods he goes out in the woods and he's
supposed to kill the baby but he's a
soldier and he feels it is it' be
dishonorable to kill a baby so what he
does is he just leaves the baby in the
woods and runs away thinking maybe the
Wolves will come and eat the baby okay
instead a Shepherd from another city
comes and finds the baby and he takes
care of the baby okay he goes home
in the city the king and queen have no
child they have no son they have no hair
okay so the shepherd presents the baby
to the king and the King names him edus
and edus grows up to be a very strong
very Noble very handsome young man when
he is of age he goes and talks to a
fortune teller the fortune teller tells
him I am sorry but you are cursed you
are cursed to kill your father and marry
your mother so edus freaks out and says
I don't want to do that I don't want to
kill my parents who love me so he runs
away from his City okay and he's going
to thieves and on the way to
thieves he gets in an argument with an
old man and his friends and he kills all
of them okay this old man happens to be
his real father the King of
Thieves he goes into thieves and
everyone's
crying and edus asks what the problem is
and the citizens there tell him well our
king is dead and also there's a
Spinx an evil demon who is haunting us
okay so edus volunteers to challenge the
spin to a duel and the spins um ask edus
a riddle if edus can get it right right
the spin will go away but if edus gets
it wrong then the spin will eat edus
okay and the riddle is what walks in the
morning with four legs what walks in the
a in the afternoon with two legs then
what walks in the evening with three
legs and the answer is yeah man okay so
it's a very famous riddle it gets it
right and the Spinx loses and he flies
away okay the people thieves are so
thankful they make him King of Thieves
if you're King of Thieves you marry the
queen of Thieves okay so he's done this
he's married his uh mother and he killed
his father okay 20 years later there's a
plague in thieves and edus now the king
knows that
somehow he's angered the gods so he
talks to a fortune teller the fortune
teller tells him
well the gods are angry at you because
you've killed your father and you've
married your mother and you've had
children of your mother okay so all your
children are products of incest so they
gods are angry at you so what edus does
is he blinds
himself and he Exiles himself okay to
die somewhere else okay now the problem
now is who inherits the throne so his
eldest son is supposed to inherit the
throne but he has another son named
pois
polyes who Rebels and he fights for the
thr the two brothers kill themselves in
battle okay they kill themselves
fighting each other and now
cron who
is
um uh the the brother to the dead queen
that the queen has killed herself okay
he now inherits a throne okay and the
first thing he does is announced that
the dead King will be given a state
funeral okay we will honor him but
polyus who rebelled against the king and
who caused all this suffering and misery
in the world he will not be given a
funeral he will not be buried and the
reason why is Greeks believe that only
by burying the dead can they find peace
in the after World okay so it's a very
serious thing not to bury the dead
anany who is the daughter of um
edus and the BR and the sister of P
poesis she finds out about this and she
thinks this is unjust poesis has done a
lot of bad things but no one deserves
this okay so she secretly buries
polyes cron finds out and demands
integnity to be arrested and cron says
to her how dare you defy my laws how
dare you disrespect my orders and the
integ says to uh him your laws are
unjust and Kanon
says the laws are the laws without laws
there will be complete chaos and then
Tey responds by saying human
laws must conform to
Justice there are these laws in the
universe ver that are Divine Unwritten
and immutable and we must respect these
laws human laws cannot override these
laws of Justice okay and this makes cron
very angry and so he sentenced her to
death for disobeying him okay the
problem is antagony is the fiance of
hymon who is Cron's son so hmon the
prince comes and begs his father to
relent
and hymon
says can you please forgive
integy and cron thinks his son has
betrayed him right your love for integy
has blinded you from seeing the truth
from doing what is right and hymon
responds and says father I'm not doing
this for integon I'm doing this for you
and the reason why is the people thieves
fully support integon they think she is
a hero they think she is just and right
to be to want to bury her brother they
think you are a
tyrant father and Kanon
says should I obey the mob should I the
king listen to the
Mob and then hmon says no you should
listen to what is right and just okay
cron gets very angry and kicks himon out
okay but then Creon has a change of
heart and he doesn't know if he's done
the right thing so he talks to a fortune
teller okay and the fortune teller tells
him um integon is right in this in this
in this situation you have to save her
if you don't save her if she dies the
gods will be very angry at you okay and
that scares cron so cron and his guards
they look for antagony but when they
find integy she's in a cave and she's
dead she's killed herself because she
doesn't want to be executed okay and we
weeping over the body of integy is hmon
he's crying he's so depressed and sad
and cron sees his son crying and he
tries to put his hand on him and console
him the moment that hymon sees his
father he becomes so angry he lunge at
him with his sword okay but he misses
and when he find out he has failed to
kill his father in his anger and in his
grief he kills himself so both anany and
hmon are now dead and when hyon's mother
finds out about this she kills himself
she kills herself too and now Kon is a
is alone in the world
okay does that make sense okay uh so
does this story make sense to you all
right now what does the story mean well
remember Athens is a
democracy and so this is a message
that's very much anti- King right like
let's not have a king because Kings do
stupid things and why do kings do do
stupid things because of
huus the problem with Kings with
monarchy with power is people develop
huis arrogance right violent excessive
arrogance and that makes them do stupid
things like listen like um refuse to
listen to what is right and good and
just that's why kingship is a bad thing
that's why we Athenians have democracy
and not a king okay so that's the first
message the second message is
basically the world
works
when the old give way to the young okay
the old must always listen to the
young so remember that in the Ora the
play ends with a furious the old gods
giving way to the new Gods who bring
Justice into the world
okay the the idus uh Trilogy ends in
tragedy because the Old King refuses to
give way to young
people okay so the other message is
society works there is truth and Justice
in the world when the old give way to
the young okay so those are the two main
messages of this play any questions so
far before I move
on
TR oh that's a great question why do
people trust the fortune tellers because
remember everyone's religious so the
fortune tellers speak on behalf of the
Gods okay they they're called
um seers or
prophets or
uh
divor okay so their job what makes them
special is they're able to interpret the
will of the Gods and that's why the
Kings listen to them okay and remember
this is for most of human history um
humans were extremely religious people
including the Greeks the Greeks were
especially incredibly religious
okay does that make
sense all
right okay any more questions before I
move on all right let's talk about um
yides okay and
yides was he's the youngest of these
three and he's the least he was the
least prized or the least respected in
Athens when he was a liive okay and the
reason why is
as you can see the Ora in the edus Rex
um
Trilogy they celebrate Athenian
democracy but ubid he criticized
Athenian
democracy right so the example is in
4115 BCE and this is the height of the
palpan war okay he put on a play called
children
woman and this play is about the
aftermath of the children War so at the
end of the children War all the children
men are killed right and the custom is
to enslave the children uh woman okay so
uh one character is hecuba and hecuba is
the queen of Troy and pram um her
husband he he's been killed
okay hecuba is a tragic figure
because um she's seen all her sons die
and then one of her daughters has been
sacrificed
killed uh for Achilles Achilles died in
in the war and achilles is dead so they
sacrificed a young girl who's a princess
of Troy he hecubus daughter in order to
accompany him in the afterworld so
either uh so all her daughters have
either been killed by the Greeks or
they've been enslaved okay and been
forced to be the mistress or
concubine of the Greek uh hero hero like
Odus okay then you have a Maki and J
Maki um is the wife of Hector the prince
of Troy who died at the hands of
Achilles okay so she saw the death of
her husband and she has a young baby
okay and this young baby is only a few
months old but he's a boy and the law at
that time is all boys must be killed
because the Greeks fear if he goes up
and he's and he's the son of Hector
right he might want revenge okay so
draki must witness the Greeks
killing um her son who's only again only
a few months old and then and then heot
is dragged away to be a slave to be
basically a mistress a lover of a Greek
General
aysus and so hecuba must personally bury
the dead child okay and so it is a play
that made everyone in Athens weep what
makes this play powerful is that the
year before 416 BCE and this is again
during the height of the palan War
Athens was attacking everyone okay
including melow an island called melow
and when they attacked Melos they killed
all the man and enslaved all the woman
so in many ways children the children
woman is a direct response to what
happened in Melos okay Europe is telling
the people do you see how terrible we
are we are a terrible people do you see
all the hurt and suffering we' brought
onto the world because of our Empire
okay now obviously thean people didn't
like this play and so he lost in the
competition to this obscure
nobody okay and Yus got really angry
about all this he was very bitter about
all this so he exiled himself to
Macedonia okay where he died okay he
died away from Athens in his last play
he wrote his last play called a
backai in Macedonia and after he died
his friends brought this play back to
Athens this play backy is considered his
Masterpiece his best play okay so again
what I will do now is I'll explain to
you the plot of the Bai and then I will
explain what the interpretation is okay
all right so um there's a God there's a
god named
diis another name for diis is bakas okay
so the baky are people who worship
dianis um the god of theater of music of
uh festivals of wine of sex okay
now um dianis The Legend is he was born
in
thieves to a fean princess and um his
father was Zeus the king of the Gods
okay Zeus likes to go around and rape
woman okay and he has many many children
including
diis but when the princess of Thieves
announced that she's been impregnated by
Zeus No One believed her everyone
laughed at her okay
and uh the people of Thieves refus to
worship dianis now diis is worshiped
around the world including in India as
far as as India so dianis has always
been bitter about all this okay he's
bitter about the fact that his wife his
mother was
insulted by the F people he's also
bitter about the fact that Fe F people
don't pay homage to him okay so he plots
his revenge what he does is he disgu
disgu himself as a Wanderer okay a
stranger and he makes the woman of
Thieves
insane okay he makes he makes them
worship him and what they do is they run
off to the mountains where they have sex
ories okay they're having like sex
they're doing all these crazy things in
the worship of
dianis the King of Thieves his name is
pentus panthus he he hears about this he
hears about all this chaos and he
decides you know what I'm going to get
my Army go in the mountains and kill
everyone okay because the baky are too
disruptive they are uh aoral
okay and he's about to do this but then
diis the wanderer tells him hey I'll
make you a deal don't kill the
backy I want to take you into the
mountains and together we can watch them
have sex together okay we can watch
their sex parties and pentas says okay
that's interesting okay so together the
two um go into the mountains and they
hide behind a rock as a backai are about
to worship
dianus panus is hiding behind the rock
you can't really see that clearly okay
but he's really excited he really wants
to see the backy in action so dianis
says why don't you climb that tree and
that tree will give you a better view of
all the action okay so pantheus climbs
the tree and he hangs by the branch okay
and he he has a very clear view of the
backy who are in a
circle then what D does is he lowers the
branch so like panthus is now in the
circle of the woman and D commands the
woman to kill pantheus to rip his body
apart okay and one of the woman in that
circle is actually pantheus
mother right okay so pantheus dies in
the um mountains the people of Thieves
are now very anxious the king um has
disappeared the woman of Thieves are in
the mountains then P's mother comes back
and and she's running she's really
excited okay and she's
holding the head of panus and she's
shuning to people of Thieves look how
wonderful I am look how Brave and
courageous and strong I am because I'm
holding a lion's head by my bare hands
with my bare hands I killed a lion and
ripped the head off his body here it is
okay and it takes a very long time for
the people thieves to convince her
that's not a lion's head man that's your
son's
head okay so this is an extremely
weird play okay very
weird and there are different
interpretations of what this means and I
and I'll tell you my interpretation
right
so a think about this image okay a
mother holds the son's head in her hand
and she's celebrating How brave she
is
right now I think this is a metaphor for
war and
Empire the reason why is war and
Empire happens when old people send
their children to die to fight and die
for their Glory does that make sense
okay so this image of a mother holding
the son holding her son's head and
shutting to the whole world look how
Brave I am look how great I am okay it's
really a metaphor or an image for war
and
Empire okay because remember the pan war
is really about building Empire right
Athens wants to build its Empire and
it's sacrificing its young people in
order to accomplish this so the bakai is
a direct criticism of the Athenian
Empire and his direct criticism of the
pelan war okay does that make sense all
right
um so some further Evidence support this
interpretation is in 431
[Music]
BC the pan war between Spartan and
Athens
started and about a year afterwards a
lot of Athenian men are dead and it is
the custom at that time to honor the war
dead by holding a huge State funeral
okay so the state Athens will pay for
the burial of all its War dead during
this huge funeral all things come out to
uh watch an
oration and so uh
Pericles who again remember we'll talk
more about Pericles later on but
Pericles he's the basically the first
citizen of Athens which basically means
he's the king of Athens okay and he
gives his funeral oration during this
time and the fation is considered by
many to be the greatest speech ever made
okay is beautiful it is um extremely
eloquent it's very
powerful in the speech he says
this Athens is the greatest place ever
and that's because we celebrate
Excellence Athens is a place where
anyone can come and through hard work
through Talent can achieve greatness we
are an open
tolerant Cosmopolitan people we have a
we have a
democracy where everyone can participate
in the Civic life the political life of
Athens that's what make Athens
glorious
therefore we must protect our democracy
through
War it is good that the young go out and
fight for our Empire our democracy
because that's what gives meaning to
their lives the these men who are dead
before us they died well because they
died protecting Athens and defending our
democracy and we should have all young
men go and fight for us okay that's a
speech that's literally what he
says so Ides was probably in the
audience right because everyone was in
the audience when when the speech was
given okay and he reimagines his fation
as the mother holding the son's head and
saying to the world look how Brave I
am okay what Pericles is really saying
is we're an Empire an Empire is so good
because it brings glory to the old
people and so the young must protect the
glory of the old people by dying in a
war does that make
sense okay
but if you think about it okay even
though Ides is criticizing Athenian
democracy what he's really doing is also
trying to defend Athenian democracy
because a democracy only
happens when citizens are engaged in a
process of argumentation debate and
self-reflection and so what ues is
really trying to do is put a
error before thean people and he's
saying toan people look how awful we are
we can do
better and that's what a democracy
really is it's an open and honest
discussion about how we can be
better
okay and
again these three um issist sopes and
Ides are considered the three greatest
playwrights
in uh Athenian history and and there
these plays are actually still performed
today okay so there Thea uh edus Rex and
the bakai are still perform in theaters
around the world
today that's how amazing uh they were so
any questions
oh okay great question okay so the baky
how do other Scholars interpret the Bai
right okay so there are different
interpretations but the most common
interpretation is it is a play that
explores um the idea of religious yield
uh religious
devotion or religious fanaticism
okay okay does that make sense that's
that's most common interpretation this
play is really about the power of
religion and faith and how it drives us
into
madness Okay that's the most common
interpretation another interpretation
is well
dianis is the villain okay he's not
really the villain but he's the main
focus of um this play and D does a lot
of bad things right well guess what for
most of his life Ides was participating
in the fesal of dines hoping
to win first place right to to be the
protagonist uh
to win first place but most of the times
he lost because he he kept on offending
thean people right so another
interpretation is this
play backa it's a satire on the power of
dionis and of theater in general okay
it's direct criticism of the Festival of
dianis and what he what what and what uh
UB is really saying is the Festival of
dianis it's
not about art and reflection and
democracy it's really just a while sex
party that's trying to please everyone
okay so so you can also interpret this
as a theism of democracy itself
democracy is just a wild sex party right
so these are the two major
interpretations that it is that the it's
about the power and dangers of religious
devotion fanaticism
okay um and also the play Bey it's a
direct attack on the idea of theater
itself and democracy okay but I don't
see it that way I think the most likely
explanation for me is it is a direct
criticism of
Empire okay and you can believe whatever
you want that's a power of Athenian
theater there are different ways to
interpreted okay so even today modern
audiences are still amazed and inspired
by these
plays any any more questions
great good question okay so
Revenge okay you're right in that all
these plays have the idea of Revenge
okay and the reason why is if you think
think about human motivation what really
drives us right what really drives us to
violence what's
revenge okay so revenge is the main plot
device we use to drive action it's what
motivates us to do violent things and
that and that's why um throughout all
these plays revenge is a common theme
okay but a very very common but another
very common theme is the idea of
hubris right hubris arrogance and this
is what the Greek um Tri uh this this is
what the Greek playwrights focus a lot
on what they discovered is
things go around in society when the
leaders when the elite when the Kings
they develop hubris okay because it
leads to bad
judgment but what they also discovered
is
hubris is just a part of human nature
okay if you put someone in a position of
power he or she will always felt hubris
so hubis is basically the most common
theme throughout all these plays and and
you're right and that revenge is also
um a very common theme as well so yeah
there are these common themes but and
the reason why is uh these play rights
these poets they're trying to explore
what it means to be human they're trying
to decipher the essence of Being Human
okay they're trying to look into the
human heart and trying to figure out
what makes
us uh uh human basically and all humans
are alike
okay okay and and any more
questions uh yeah the Athenians okay so
the thing the thing about Ides um was
that we today Scholars will all agree
all these three Ides was the most
talented meaning his use of poetry his
use of metaphors imagery it was the most
imaginative okay we also agree that he
is um the
most um shocking okay his ideas uh the
way he presents things it is the most
Visual and imaginative okay so in terms
of pure talent he's he's the most
talented um but when he was alive okay
he was an extremely arrogant person who
belied theater should be about Awakening
people should be challenging people's
sense of
reality okay it should be it should be
about education and
edification and these people tend to be
hated by contemporaries okay but after
they dead later generations respect them
more so even though uh children woman
did not win first place the Bai did win
first place and that's because well
yides was dead
okay and they were able to see the
genius and Imagination of the bakai much
more uh closely okay does does that make
sense okay so you you ubid basically had
um um his his IM His Image his
reputation um was rejuvenated after his
death but during his lifetime he was he
was despised by a lot of people okay
people respected his genius but they
didn't like the fact that he was so
arrogant and candid
okay and that's true for most of human
history where where you know if you are
a controversial writer you are not
respected by contemporaries but after
you're dead people appreciate your
Genius okay and this is true for Mo most
really famous
writers any more
questions these are great questions by
the way
okay great so uh next class we will do
Socrates and Playdoh okay